[Music]  Mariah Carey is soaking up the Sun in  paradise sometimes as long a length Lea  excursion lengthy indeed mimi is  enjoying a nice long six weeks off from  her Las Vegas residency to enjoy a  vacation with her dancer beau Bryan  Tanaka while also spending quality time  with her seven-year-old twins Moroccan  and Monroe the twin thing is it's  difficult okay this is not okay I know  it's a shock but I'm not gonna be scared  Mariah may be nervous about swimming  with sharks but she appears to be  enjoying every second relaxing aboard a  yacht the pop diva has been documenting  her get away with the cutest vacation  pics  here's Mariah and her mini-me Monroe  striking identical poses together and  the whole family admiring the sunset  before mom has to head back to work I've  been working hard so  [Music]